[Música]
el vih es el virus de inmunodeficiencia
humana
si padece vih tiene una infección que
daña su sistema inmune con el tiempo y
que ocasiona sida
sida significa síndrome de
inmunodeficiencia adquirida
es la etapa final de una infección por
vih en la que su sistema inmune se daña
y se debilita demasiado como para lidiar
con las infecciones cotidianas
cuando los invasores externos por
ejemplo bacterias y virus
ingresan a su cuerpo pueden provocar
infecciones
estos eventos activan las defensas del
cuerpo los glóbulos blancos del sistema
inmune son parte de las defensas de su
cuerpo un tipo de glóbulo blanco
denominado linfocito t colaborador o
célula t colaboradora fortalece la
respuesta del sistema inmune ante una
infección de dos maneras primero las
células de colaboradoras liberan
químicos que atraen a otras células
blancas hasta el lugar de la infección
estos glóbulos blancos adicionales
atacan a la bacteria o al virus invasor
así como a otras células infectadas
luego las células de colaboradoras
liberan químicos que hacen que los demás
glóbulos blancos se multipliquen
estos nuevos glóbulos blancos crean
marcadores llamados anticuerpos que
pueden identificar este mismo invasor
externo en todo el cuerpo
los anticuerpos se adhieren a la
bacteria o al virus y los marcan como
objetivos para que el sistema
inmunológico los destruya
si padece vih este viaja a través de su
sangre y otros líquidos corporales para
infectar y matar ciertos glóbulos
blancos
el virus ingresa a las células t
colaboradoras que son el objetivo
principal
una vez dentro
el virus hace muchas copias de sí mismo
a medida que se realizan estas
partículas del virus de jaén la célula t
colaboradora dañada para infectar otras
células
la célula te pierde su habilidad de
proteger al cuerpo de esta infección y
muere
[Música]
de este modo el vih se propaga y mata
más células de colaboradoras lo que
debilita su sistema inmune
[Música]
como resultado otro tipo de infecciones
pueden aprovecharse de la incapacidad de
su cuerpo de defenderse
estas infecciones se denominan
infecciones oportunistas
si padece una infección por vih y una o
más infecciones oportunistas
padece sida
algunas de las infecciones oportunistas
más comunes relacionadas con el sida son
inflamación de los tejidos que cubren el
cerebro y la médula ósea denominada
meningitis
inflamación del cerebro denominada
encefalitis
enfermedades respiratorias como la
neumonía y la tuberculosis
enfermedades intestinales como la
diarrea crónica provocada por parásitos
infecciosos
y cáncer como sarcoma de kaposi y
linfoma no-hodgkin
el vih pasa de persona en persona a
través de líquidos corporales infectados
el vih puede ingresar a su cuerpo
durante un encuentro sexual sin
protección mientras comparte agujas de
drogas inyectables durante su propio
nacimiento por parte de su madre durante
la lactancia o por sangre o productos
sanguíneos contaminados
si bien no hay cura para el vih los
fármacos denominados medicamentos
antirretrovirales pueden reducir la
cantidad de vih en el cuerpo
una clase de medicamento antirretroviral
denominada inhibidores de la entrada o
la fusión irrumpe el proceso de
infección de vih al evitar que el virus
se adhiera a sus células
y otras clases de medicinas
antirretrovirales incluyen inhibidores
de transcriptasa inversa
inhibidores de la proteasa e inhibidores
de la integrasa
estos fármacos evitan que se creen se
agrupan y se propaguen los nuevos virus
es posible que su médico le prescribe
una combinación de estas clases de
fármacos conocidos como terapia
antirretroviral altamente efectiva y h&r
de los medicamentos antirretrovirales no
eliminan por completo el vih de su
cuerpo pero lo ralentizan lo suficiente
como para permitir que el sistema inmune
luche contra las infecciones las pruebas
de sangre regulares permitirán que su
médico sepa cuán efectivo es un
medicamento antirretroviral para
controlar el vih
si la cantidad de células de
colaboradoras en su muestra de sangre es
lo suficientemente alta significa que el
medicamento está funcionando los
tratamientos para las infecciones
oportunistas para el sida son
medicamentos específicos para cada tipo
de infección
por ejemplo es posible que su médico le
prescribe antibióticos y padece neumonía
o tuberculosis
para evitar obtener una infección por
vih o que ésta se propague realice
pruebas regularmente para conocer su
estado de vih y el de su pareja el modo
más efectivo de evitar una infección por
vih es evitar el sexo vaginal y anal
en el momento de involucrarse en la
actividad sexual es menos probable que
contraiga vih si solo tiene sexo con una
pareja no infectada o si se protege con
condones de látex
evite usar drogas ilegales inyectables o
compartir agujas de drogas ya que las
agujas pueden contener el virus
evite la intoxicación con drogas o
alcohol ya que es más probable que se
involucre en alguna actividad sexual no
segura